Speaker 1: New report from Maggie Haberman of The
New York Times is that Donald Trump is furious
over his humiliating losses on Tuesday. Is tantrum
ing like a child and blaming everyone around him,
even his wife, Melania? Check out these tweets
from The New York Times's Maggie Haberman. Quote,
Trump is indeed furious this morning,
particularly about Mehmet Oz and is blaming
everyone who advised him to back Oz, including
his wife, describing it as not her best decision.
According to people close to him now, there is
truth to the fact. As I said earlier, that if
Trump had gone with David McCormick rather than
Mehmet Oz in the Pennsylvania Republican primary,
McCormick probably would have won. He only lost
by 951 votes. He probably would have won. I do
think Trump's endorsement gained Oz a little over
900 votes. That's totally plausible. Had McCormick
won. You might have had a completely different
situation in Pennsylvania because there were
Republicans who said, Oz, this guy's a clown. He's
not even from Pennsylvania. This doesn't make any
sense. Now, Trump saying Melania was one of the
people that told him to do that. That's pretty
interesting. Maggie Haberman continuing quote,
There are people pushing Trump to reschedule his
announcement next week. And several Republicans
have texted, asking whether he will. But it's
risky and would be acknowledging he's wounded by
yesterday, something that some advisers insist is
not the case. This is the point about narcissism,
that I made a narcissist. You know, we many of us
who don't have these personality tendencies,
we sometimes trick ourselves into believing,
you know what, this guy who can't ever just admit,
you know what I got I got outrun I straight up
loss. Once it's verified and and validated that
Joe Biden won and Biden's inaugurated, Trump's
not going to have any choice but to say, you know
what, I lost and we were wrong. It's two years
later and Trump is still saying it was stolen.
In my personal life, I've had situations with
oftentimes it's with pathological liars who
sometimes are also extreme narcissists. Were
in my head, I go, Wow, at this point, they're
not going to be able to keep up the lie anymore.
They're going to have to just say, you know
what? I made that up. And they never do.
They find a way around it. And the way that this
applies to Trump is we all see Twitter, Dickson,
Mehmet Oz, Doug Mastriano. We don't know yet
about Carrie Lee. You know, we're still counting.
It wasn't a good night for Trump's critical
contested endorsements. He has no choice at
this point to just say, wow, I really messed up
right now. He's blaming his wife. He's potentially
going forward with this completely harebrained
announcement on Tuesday. All right. Last tweet
from Maggie Haberman, quote, Worth remembering,
Trump is a grown man who endorsed Oz over the
objection of some of the people closest to him and
instead went beyond just endorsing and attacked
Dave McCormick from the stage at a rally. Yeah,
it's important to remember, we're dealing with a
nearly 80 year old man. It's my wife's fault.
That's what he's going with. It's completely
pathetic and ridiculous. Now, the question is,
does he heed the calls to delay the announcement?